this sort of came up last week and I got
an audience question about it that's
interesting and the question is hey
David a lot of liberals oppose nuclear
technology aren't liberals wrong to
oppose nuclear technology I've actually
talked about this before and whenever I
say this I end up angering almost
everybody on the one hand it's
absolutely true that we should not be
looking to nuclear energy as the panacea
for the long term of humanity we should
be looking at alternative and renewable
sources of energy we know that humanity
is able to harness those renewable and
alternative sources of energy in a way
that they can provide for all of our
energy needs
don't fall for the right wing talking
point that alternative and renewable
energy can never provide the energy that
we need
I think we're liberals sometimes go
wrong is it's true that there are risks
to nuclear energy but new nuclear that
would be put in place now has so
significantly dealt with a lot of those
risks that the sort of expected value
the expected likelihood of a major
disaster is very very low and there's a
lot of people on the Left who don't like
to hear that so what I've said before
and what I will repeat is that I am not
opposed to nuclear tech nuclear energy
as a bridge to getting off of some of
these dirtier fossil fuels like coal and
others while we ramp up truly
alternative and renewable sources of
energy and I think that the left should
be more open to that you do run into a
practical question though which is that
to significantly increase nuclear
capacity takes a while and there's a
question and there is disagreement about
this there's really good studies that
argue both sides of this there's the
question of by the time you get
significant new nuclear capacity up and
running shouldn't we or couldn't we
already be heavily transitioned off of
fossil fuels and over to alternatives
and renewables anyway and I and
that is where I am sort of less certain
but I do believe that there is a
reflexive anti-nuclear stands that many
on the Left take which I would like to
see sort of replaced with a more
pragmatic nuclear energy technology has
changed significantly over the last 40
years it is significantly safer and
while we shouldn't be for it
for the long term being open to
increases in nuclear energy capacity as
a bridge to getting off of fossil fuels
is something I wish that progressives
would be more willing to consider send
me your thoughts we've got a great bonus
show for you today the show doesn't have
to end now if you are a member or a
patron you can get instant access to the
bonus show another 15 to 20 minutes
every day just for our paid subscribers
hope to speak to you then